bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors ce
procès c'est vrai était ultra médiatisé
montré en parallèle de manifestations
anti raciste et anti violence policière
est-ce que cela a pu avoir une influence
sur le verdict comme le prétend l'avocat
de david chauvine aujourd'hui c'est le
cas car un des jurés a dit dans les
médias qu'ils se sentent est inquiet
qu'il avait perdu sa famille qu'il
craignait que la foule se rendent chez
lee que ces informations soient
diffusées auprès du public
il semblerait que les mêmes choses peut
arriver à beaucoup de personnes dont
beaucoup de lieux à cause de ces foules
qui voulait le verdict un verdict très
spécifiques et effectivement ils ont
contenu leur verdict qu'il souhaitait
car lui avait peur de voter différemment
il n'a pas dit qu'il avait modifié son
vote mais il a clairement dit qu'il
avait peur de la réaction de la foule
contre lui ou sa famille s'il avait voté
pour l'acquittement
il faut se demander combien les autres
jurés ressentez la même chose sans le
dire surtout après que maxime wenders
tel taux d'écouté et contribuer à ces
termes aux sphères en lui disant qu'il
fallait condamner derek chauvin et aux
jurés a également pris part à des
rassemblements du réel elle est amorti
lorsqu'on lui a demandé ce qu'il faisait
s'ils y avaient participé
donc c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles il a été sélectionné il a
donné une interview dans laquelle il a
dit qu'en tant que militant nous devons
être intégrée d'intel jurés pour pouvoir
influencer les résultats
donc c'est très clairement un mutant blm
qui veut influencer le verdict plutôt
qu'un jury impartial
à cause de cette personne on peut donc
suspecté que davantage de personnes
étaient comportement du même genre et
donc effectivement il pourrait y avoir
un deuxième procès clairement le nom
d'iphone perkins la défense de derek
chauvine ne cherche-t-elle pas à
politiser le verdict verdict est déjà
politisé et plaques l'animateur s'en est
assuré car certains avocats ont essayé
de revenir aux faits et je pense que
c'est une question de politique ce
verdict il n'avait pas l'intention de
tuer cet homme donc il n'est pas
coupable de meurtre bien qu'il ait été
arrogant qu'il est
arras est cet homme mais cela n'est pas
du meurtre c'est un homicide
et c'est le seul chef d'inculpation qui
aurait dû être accepté donc il n'est pas
un meurtrier
vous parlez de ces manifestations est
évidemment de cette politisation on le
sert les policiers américains sont sous
pression depuis la sphère de georges le
feu des manifestations qui ont suivi est
ce que clairement l'administration trump
a laissé pourrir ce malaise dans la
police n'aurait fait que ce que je pense
que c'est la situation dans les rues les
manifestations la violence les
destructions qui sont une tentative de
se débarrasser de donald trump ou
réparer il s'agissait d'assurer que je
n'attrape ne soit pas réélu ce sont des
réactions à la présence de donald trump
à la maison blanche donald trump n'a pas
coché cela on ne veut pas lui reprocher
c'est une stratégie nationale par un
je trouve que deux personnes en colère
afin de s'assurer que la troupe ne soit
pas le fait qu'il ait été élu président
a scandalisé beaucoup de personnes à
gauche de ce point de vue on pourrait
dire qu'il a causés mais on ne peut pas
dire qu'il ait provoqué ces
manifestations à part par le simple fait
qu'il était président un coq tant de
personnes les tester et ai voulu
s'assurer que ne soit pas réélu
aujourd'hui clairement l'arrivée de joe
biden est ce qu'elle à apaiser ces
tensions
je ne pense pas ils veulent ce qu'ils
veulent et ce qu'ils veulent
va au delà des limites de la loi de la
société de la culture
je ne pense pas que joe biden et ses
équipes puissent se permettre de céder
sur tous ces points et cela pourrait
causer une perte une défaite lors des
élections suivantes drm leïla d'extrême
gauche n'ont aucun repos tant que jobs
hayden n'accédera pas leur demande
non je pense que la pression va
augmenter tout comme elle a augmenté
face à donald trump
la bataille n'est pas finie est-ce qu'on
peut s'imaginer voir de nouvelles
émeutes comme il y en a eu au lendemain
de la mort de georges floyd je pense que
c'est déjà le cas à simplement les
médias ne s'intéressent pas bhl cours
car les médias sont du côté des
démocrates et ils savent que les
américains n'aiment pas voir ce genre
d'émeutes à la télévision n'aime pas
imaginer qu'elle arrive et imaginent et
crans voter contre le parti qui le
permet lors des élections suivantes
donc ils minimisent ces émeutes ces
événements afin d'empêcher la couleur de
se développer contre le démocrate de
s'exprimer dans les urnes
mais oui il ya toujours des émeutes et
je pense que cela va continuer
on était arrivé
mais elle elle n'obtient pas
satisfaction de joe biden donc je pense
que la violence les manifestations
continueront dans l'avenir
merci beaucoup d perkins cette analyse
politique merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france